hey qui Phil barber Santa Rosa Press  Democrat I think most coaches and  players in this league would put you  amongst the very best players in the NBA  but you don't you probably don't have as  much popular fame as some other guys  like the bran and Steph Curry  do you prefer to fly under the radar  little does it ever bother you that you  don't have as much notoriety as some  other guys no I mean am I playing a game  for that reason you know you're playing  to have fun trying to be the best player  I could be you know I'm happy with  myself in you know what I've done in my  career and you know I'm just gonna keep  going from there it's not about me being  famous or want to have more family in  those guys it's it's about me playing  basketball and having fun on the floor  finally